so what's cooler than a dog wearing a
t-shirt riding a scooter
well let's ask ij of course
what's that the dog's cooler
i heard i just seen a spot of hemway
twitter question so this first question
comes from phillyd and he asks if i
could be any male youtuber who would i
be
of course that would be sexy phil he's
so sexy he's not sexy he's us xe jay
carl wants to know if i would kiss a
random guy on the lips that just came up
to my table at a restaurant and say
actually i'm gonna turn this back around
to you
shay
would you kiss a random dude on the lips
that came up to you in a restaurant
fantastic i jason underscore wants to
know if i'm going to answer the
questions from philly d and shay carl
and i guess i already answered that
question by answering their two
questions look at this okay wants to
know if i were to create a new language
what would it sound like it would sound
like this
clintus is asking if i could do a collab
with any youtuber on youtube who would i
do a collab with and i'm going to turn
this question around also to you guys
because i would probably want to do a
collab with every single person on
youtube at the same time so if you
were to do a collab on youtube who would
you want to do a collab with jenny zarik
is asking what am i eating and since
she's my sister i'm gonna probably guess
she's eating either a grilled cheese or
pizza because my sister's a vegetarian
but she's a vegetarian that doesn't
really eat vegetables basically the only
thing that she eats is cheese pasta
and hope that's it genuine joe was
asking denzel washington and i'm going
to answer with hand
joey from winterspring pro wants to know
what my favorite n64 game was and let me
tell you what that's mario freaking cart
daily booth question pixel princess
wants to know if i'm an angry birds
addict and let me tell you what i wasn't
until recently i had a really long
flight and i played the entire time and
now we're talking about iphone games
check out pig rockets because it's also
super addicting sarah sneak what's my
favorite true blood character well my
favorite true blood character is
definitely not sucky
hey yo marco do i like ducks no
i don't know why i got so angry i don't
know why i don't like ducks because i
actually do like ducks what we have here
ladies and gentlemen is the oh he just
crap he just he just pooped oh my
goodness oh boy big dusty my favorite
coffee mug is this one it's from sheetz
mr bobby joe do i like jersey shore no
will i dye my hair black no facebook
question sarah have i ever drank water
out of a big metal spoon no
i haven't done that one if i had to live
without a toilet shower or a bedroom
which would i choose well i would
definitely choose the bedroom because
i could sleep in the shower why do i
carry an xbox controller in my purse
because you never know when you need to
get your game on i got my sac friends on
amazon
what do i think of the song friday by
rebecca black i think that there is no
comparison justin bieber if one more
person compares rebecca black to justin
bieber i'm going to flip out justin
bieber is talented and rebecca black is
not jessica wants to know what i do when
i have friendship problems and usually i
just unfriend that person on facebook
and all my problems just go away
brittany if i were to make my own video
game what would it be well most likely
would probably be a first person shooter
i would probably be shooting things
that's all i got please put me in your
ass gadget episode comment here's some
comments from people that wanted to be
in this episode of ask ij and if you'd
like to be in a future episode just
leave your comments below saying justine
please put me in an episode of ask ij
and of course the more creative your
responses are
the more chances you've got to be right
here
leave your comments below you can leave
more than one you can leave two you can
leave five it's up to you thanks so much
for watching this episode of ask ij as
always be sure to subscribe by clicking
here and you can check out the rest of
my youtube channels here you can ask me
questions on twitter you can ask me
questions on the facebook on the daily
booth blah blah blah blah blah where's
my sak friends i got one
bye